welcome to this video playing doom
diderot die die dropped I don't know ok
Queens gambit down the other the
classical with Bishop e7 then playing
with Bishop for my usual choice b6 not a
bad line one of the lines that oh you
should 86 and can move hmm yeah could
take on d5 or play play Queens yeah
let's protect with the Queen the problem
with a move like Bishop a success that
possibly the light squares get get to be
vulnerable so after you've played p6
yeah this is very very ambitious what is
dying
posting everything on the most active
possible squares even if they are
hanging and so on okay let's see the
center is some is one noble here maybe
it's okay but it feels a bit tricky okay
let's let's take here it's probably
necessary yeah if he takes with the
night he's got a week see porn yeah
probably still along the right move
interesting should I play Bishop b5 I
guess so not clear many ideas but then
this is probably a good move
Oh actually wanted to take on d5 first
okay yeah this wasn't what I wanted
reitställe it's still pretty good too
but not my original intention okay
knight c6 this looks tricky and visited
needs to go back to c7 and it's all a
bit a bit shaky move like Queen B 5
maybe you must play Bishop f6 am
intending Queen c5 Roxy aid yeah
and yeah very very strange stuff it's
not even clear if I'm Evan pattaya after
rook c8
I hope t6 sometimes just drooped istics
of course I completely forgot that I
have up to six and then obviously I need
to take on c5 everything else is just
worse this was stupid to lose any any
time on this
it's still not completely easy but then
yeah yeah check to need to do do that
he's got Bishop me God rook takes III m
yeah Roxy one made lost the thread
that wasn't a medieval but still without
a tree you cannot play this this
position pretty pretty clear okay lie to
him be one rupee 7am just play on just
play for the activity rootschat again
this is a chatot don't mind so much
yeah maybe Quincy to or something double
attacking 82 and f2 okay I don't want to
play material down its active but not
clear on how to proceed gather some
pretty pretty diverse blundered Graham
are drawn with 48 seconds it's not a
good idea to try something yeah of
course this is a game that Y term what
should win right out of the opening
because this isn't isn't good ready why
not say I should get some some big edge
but somehow somehow it didn't work out
here I had an item I wanted to take here
first but I've forgot about that
headblade rook rook here my intention
was i'm not sure if it is any better my
intention was to play that maybe this
isn't great at home I don't know I can
take him now this isn't so great him
yeah maybe I you know I always two major
things here yeah this looks very nice
but Bishop f6 is a good reply he could
have played this smooth and now rook b8
to be 6 and black wins oh ok yeah and
around here I maybe had some way to Luke
take c6 I can play just you put
yeah well probably deserve to all we
both didn't do much good in this game
thanks for watching